man can a guy take a vacation without
something insane happening at the oscars
as you probably know will smith slap the
[ __ ] out of chris rock
as a lawyer i have some thoughts about
this
but first let's look at the video you
know who's got the hardest job tonight
javier beldem and his wife are both
nominated
now if she loses he can't win
okay so the funny thing about this setup
is that it's kind of pedestrian
he's poking fun at uh javier bardem and
his wife who he doesn't name which you
really should
and he's just kind of ribbing creating
fake marital strife and of course he's
going to turn to will and jada in a
second but it's kind of a pedestrian
setup and like the joke is there's fake
strife there he is praying that will
smith wins like please
lord
jada i love you g.i jane two can't wait
to see it all right so here will smith
laughs kind of a chuckle not much jada's
clearly not happy about that of course
the back story here is that jada pinkett
smith suffers from alopecia so she
shaved her head because she was losing
her hair this is a medical condition it
is a disease and of course i'm sure
she's incredibly self-conscious about it
it's jalazad that was a nice one okay
and the crowd turns on chris rock you
can imagine another universe where
the next day basically chris rock gets
cancelled because he makes fun of jada
because of a medical condition all for a
stupid joke that's a callback to a movie
that's 20 years old and the the audience
hated it like they were against chris
rock and he's like ah that's just a
gentle ribbing and yeah true
it's not much it's that's that's really
really uh mild as these kind of roasts
go and on top of it the crowd was
already against rock this is this is an
insane setup for what happens next i'm
out here oh
okay
so will smith gets up chris rock here is
just laughing because i think he thinks
it's a bit and also this could be
completely fake it could be a made-up
drama they could have agreed to this
ahead of time we'll talk about the legal
ramifications of that but it looks
genuine like chris rock is going to
engage in some colloquy with will smith
as part of a bit like making the joke
leaning into the joke of course he leans
in a different way
wow okay so to me that doesn't look like
a punch that looks like an open fisted
slap he comes from below
he slaps chris rock across the face you
would think the guy who played
muhammad ali who trained like muhammad
ali will smith uh would know how to
throw a real punch and i don't think
that that's what he's doing there i
don't think he's throwing a real punch
and we'll talk about the ramifications
of this open fisted slap
wow
will smith just smacked out of me
you gotta hand it to chris rock though
handles it like a pro is physically
accosted and just rolls with it without
missing a beat i mean i guess that's
that's why he's chris rock
wow dude
yeah it was a g.i james keep my wife's
name out
i'm going to okay man
you think there's got to be some past
history here and we'll talk about what
that means
that doesn't seem like a normal reaction
to
a lame joke that's really modest but
he's clearly furious that's very
interesting that he's that angry we'll
see if that plays into
the charges the potential charges and
the potential defenses
but that is a really weird reaction how
often do you hear about people
physically assaulting people for
a mild dig like this
oh okay
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television okay
and then chris rock tries to play it off
with a joke um i i would love to know if
chris rock has ever been accosted in a
comedy set i mean he's taken bigger
shots
at much more violent people and yet
here we are
in the oscars and will smith
slaps it and then of course will smith
wins the oscar for best actor
that's just insane i'm actually
surprised that the academy went through
with awarding it
given that in the past people like
jeremy clarkson have been fired from
some of the most
popular tv shows in the world i'm kind
of surprised that the academy went
through and gave will smith his award he
of course made a pseudo apology during
his acceptance speech and in the past
will smith has talked about not wanting
to be a vessel for violence and being a
vessel for love uh it is incredibly
ironic uh that all of this happened at
roughly exactly the same time just
insane okay so right off the bat let's
talk about whether this constitutes
assault and battery and obviously it
depends because everything always
depends i'm just kidding this is
definitely assault and battery under
california penal code 240 assault is the
attempt to use violence against someone
it's not the actual physical violence
itself it is the attempt battery on the
other hand is the actual physical
touching and the physical force and
violence against somebody else
specifically california penal code 242
defines battery as the any willful or
unlawful use of force or violence
against the person of another now you
can be prosecuted for battery even if
you don't cause any physical injury or
pain really all that's required is that
you physically touch that person and
simple battery is a misdemeanor that
carries with it a potential six months
in jail that's the maximum and a two
thousand dollar fine now obviously those
maximums aren't dished out uh on the
regular now obviously here since chris
rock was able to continue with the set
almost like nothing happened you can
understand that
he didn't really suffer any long-lasting
injury or pain he just kind of rolled
with it but just because chris rock
didn't suffer any demonstrable pain or
injury and obviously he felt pain when
he was slapped but it's probably no
ongoing injury there that doesn't mean
that will smith cannot be prosecuted for
assault and battery though by the same
token the fact that will smith did not
use a close-fisted punch with all of his
might that probably means that if
potential charges came they're not going
to be the maximum the police have better
things to do than press these kind of
charges but you can imagine if he did
punch chris rock muhammad ali style that
maybe that would convince the district
attorney to move forward and that might
up the charges to something
on the more severe end of the charges
that you can bring simply because it
would have injured chris rock more now
this almost goes without saying but i'm
going to say it anyway a lot of people
have brought up the self-defense
argument here uh defending your wife
from hurtful words does not qualify as a
justification for using self-defense or
any kind of force against another person
though if chris rock consented to it
that would defeat it if will smith did
agree ahead of time with chris rock to
engage in this punch
for the publicity or whatever then that
would mitigate any charges consent would
be a defense to this kind of assault and
battery additionally some people are
throwing around the first amendment
exception of fighting words this
definitely doesn't qualify as fighting
words again this is just a joke a bad
joke against another person basically uh
the whole words are violence crew on
twitter very very wrong in many
different ways there is no justification
for using force against someone who just
says mean things against you at least no
legal justification and in fact i
actually found a california jury
instruction the law that is given to the
jury in a case like this that
specifically says that words cannot give
rise to violence specifically the jury
instructions say words no matter how
offensive and acts that are not
threatening are not enough to justify
assault or battery uh yeah so fighting
words not applicable here now that being
said a lot of different news sites are
reporting that chris rock doesn't want
to file charges doesn't want to press
charges against will smith and as if
that ends the inquiry it actually
doesn't uh
almost always even if the victim decides
not to press charges against someone a
district attorney can still move forward
with the case now there are certainly
some pragmatic considerations that if
the main witness who was the victim of a
crime doesn't want to testify well then
you're going to have a hard time proving
your case and a lot of people have said
online that you know if chris rock
doesn't want to testify there's no way
that they can authenticate the video or
you know make the case i guarantee if
the police wanted to press these charges
they don't need to call chris rock they
could call anyone that was in the
auditorium at the time
those people could authenticate the
videotape and they could testify as to
their first-hand witnessing as to what
happened so that's to say that the
normal considerations where the victim
is the only witness to a crime don't
apply here there are hundreds if not
thousands of witnesses who can not only
testify to direct
witnessing that they did but can
authenticate the videotape that was
internationally broadcast around the
world but the bottom line here is that
will smith started making trouble in his
neighborhood he got in one little fight
it's time that he move in with his
auntie and uncle in bel air hopefully
this video doesn't get demonetized
because of the violence and the cursey
words that were used throughout but if
it does you should go watch an ad free
version of this video over on nebula
where i have all of my exclusive content
including my first documentary bad law
words good
videos that are exclusive to nebula
because i always have to worry about my
content getting demonetized on youtube
and in fact now is a great time to get
access to nebula because we have an
exclusive deal with curiosity stream
which has some of the greatest
documentary content on the internet and
you can get a bundle deal between
curiosity stream and nebula where you
get nebula for free so if you enjoy
legal eagle if you would like exclusive
content that you can't find anywhere
else bloopers extended versions new
videos my first long-form documentary
bad law words good all of that content
is available exclusively on nebula which
you can get for free with curiosity
stream just by using the link that is on
screen right now there's simply no
better deal in streaming right now you
get two great streaming platforms for
less than fifteen dollars per year at
the current sales price and you'll
actually watch that content plus you'll
be helping out educational content
creators like myself so click on the
link that's on screen right now or down
in the description to get both nebula
and curiosity stream for less than
fifteen dollars per day and while you're
there click on this playlist over here
with all of my other reactions to crazy
legal things uh sometimes it's drama
sometimes it's the oscars so click on
this link or i'll see you in court